هذان المقاتلان الأمريكيان
مقيّدان خلفهما وهما
يرتديان زيًا موحدًا وليس زيهما ،
وربما تم أسرهما من قبل
الروس أنفسهم الذين كانوا يقاتلون
هذا بقدر ما هو خبر
سار للرفيق الذي آخر  رأيت دبابة t-72
فتحت النار على صديقين له ، هل هذا
يمنحك أي نوع من
الأسباب للأمل
تمامًا أتمنى أن أقول
على يقين مائة بالمائة
أنه ليس مزيفًا ولكن لدي الكثير من
الأمل في ذلك  إنه جندي أمريكي سابق
كان في نفس معركة
أليكس دروكي وآندي وين عندما
فقدوا في المعركة
يخشى الانتقام الروسي في أوكرانيا
وخارجها ويريد
إخفاء هويته وصوته ، يستخدم الاسم الرمزي بيب
ولكن للمرة الأولى
وصف على شاشة التلفزيون ما حدث في التاسع من حزيران (يونيو) على بعد
حوالي 20 ميلاً شمال شرق خاركيف ،
تم إرسال الفريق في مهمة في
التاسع وظهروا في منطقة
العمليات وكان هجوم روسي مدرع واسع النطاق
قيد التنفيذ على عجل.
تم إنشاء فريقين مضادين للدبابات من efense تم تشكيلهما من قبل
أليكس وأطلق آندي قذيفة آر بي جي
على BMP كان قادمًا عبر
الغابة ودمره T-72 ثم أدار برجه
وأطلق النار عليهم
قادوا بضعة أمتار أخرى للأمام وضربهم.
اللغم المضاد للدبابات الذي وضعه ضابطنا الأوكراني ،
نشتبه في أنه تم
تدميره إما بإطلاق دبابة T-72
عليهم أو انفجار
اللغم
حتى الآن نفى المسؤولون الروس أي
معرفة عن الأمريكيين المفقودين